bonsoir garde 16 merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur arte france pour vous que
signifie cette nouvelle sanction du
réseau social bonsoir madame écouter
dans la dans la tradition juridique
française ça vient contredire le la
liberté d'expression et surtout la
liberté d'information qui suppose 2-2
droit le droit d'informer et le droit
d'être informés ils compris par une
presse d'opinion alors avec la limite
qui est posée par l'article 11 de la
déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen et qui hélas l'injure et la
diffamation dans cette liberté mais rt
france 2 s'est rendu coupable ni
d'injures ni de diffamation ni de propos
à caractère antisémite homophobe raciste
voilà deux pas de propos condamnables à
votre actif donc pour un juriste
français cette façon arbitraire même si
twitter reste maître de sa façon de
modérer les propos
ce ne peut que surprendre dans ce
contexte m est ce qu'on peut parler de
discrimination ou de guerre idéologique
de la part de twitter alors il ya des
discriminations qui sont recevables
endroits on a le droit de choisir de
pied on décide de diffuser les propos
mais précisément à raison de sept
articles 11 et de la loi de 1881 du 29
juillet 1881 la façon dont on choisit de
ne pas relayer les propos de d'un des
médias doit être justifiée et ça le
tribunal de paris l'a rappelé notamment
puisque là il ya un objectif affiché de
lutte contre les fraudes informations le
tribunal de paris l'a rappelé dans un
jugement récent où il a précisé que les
allégation ou imputation inexactes ou
trompeuses d'un à fait de nature à
altérer la sincérité d'un scrutin à
venir doit être proulx
donc il faut pour pouvoir le faire
d'abord relier cette discrimination à
une élection est prouvé en quoi les
propos que l'on refuse de diffuser
auprès de nature à fausser le jeu
électoral
vous l'avez dire vous venez nous nous
l'expliqué manière complète que c'est le
réseau social dont qui désignait
effectivement les métiers a joué sans
voilà qui voulait diffuser je les sens
d'une indépendance éditoriale mais selon
quel critère est ce qu'il ya une
transparence par rapport à cela alors
vous vous faites allusion je pense aux
d'algorithmes que revendique twitter
pour modérer des propos et le mode de
fonctionnement la méthode de calcul de
ces algorithmes et inconnues donc voilà
ça aussi c'est un autre sujet qui pose
une question c'est quelles sont les
critères qui permettent de d'éliminer
des propos du réseau social et notamment
ceux qui est joint à la question qui
vous anime pourquoi est-ce que depuis le
19 août vous avez disparu de la barre de
recherche
alors en plus de recevoir un libellé les
médias visés n'auront plus la même porte
qu'avant c'est bien de cela qu'il s'agit
pour qu'on comprenne bien
mais oui vous avez tout à fait compris
si vous voulez c'est ce que je vous
disais dans mon propos introductif le
droit à l'information c'est 2 3 le droit
d'informer
est ce le droit à être informé et là
c'est le droit à être informés par
l'usagé du compte twitter qui est mis en
péril par la disparition du
référencement de votre médium comment
vous voyez l'évolution des réseaux
sociaux justement dans les années
à venir ça dépendra beaucoup créé
communiqué communiqué c'est une question
politique il faut pas se masquer
l'information est nécessairement un
enjeu de lutte et de conflits qui
suppose un débat organisé permanent
alors tout le tout le problème ça sera
l'organisation du débat à l'avenir et
cette organisation de l'espace
médiatique des formes d'appropriation
des médias et des pouvoirs dont dispose
les producteurs et les destinataires de
l'information va déterminer la qualité
de la formation que dont nous sommes les
consommateurs ou les usagers seconde à
la chapelle intellectuelle à laquelle on
appartient
merci car on 16 pour cet éclairage
rappelle que vous êtes avocat au barreau
de paris merci à vous